bien bonjour bonjour jean baptiste
bonjour stéphane nous allons voir
aujourd'hui une variante extrêmement
pointus qui s'appelle alors dans une
drôle de danse puisque c'est leur avion
de kalachnikov
c'est un an qui va bien avec la variante
comme tout l'esprit c'est une variante
de sicilienne qui appartient à la
famille des systèmes pélicans ont dit on
va voir que c'est avec un coût 1,5 très
vite qui stratégiquement à l'air assez
douteux et on va voir qu'il ya beaucoup
de si ce qu'il vienne qui ressemble à
celle ci celle ci a des spécificités
c'est pour ça qu'on consacre deux leçons
une ouverture qui est très intéressante
qui est très dynamique avec des concepts
positionnelle assez pointu encore une
fois
il ya 6 7 6 qui viennent qui se
ressemble un petit peu on dit qu'il ya
environ
entre 25 et 30 sicilienne différentes
voilà ça c'est sa part tient une petite
famille qui s'appelle d'estienne
kalachnikov kalachnikov amis pélican on
va rappeler quand même que la
kalachnikov c'est une arme russe fusils
d'assaut oui à la base mais voilà un
fusil d'assaut russe
donc c'est pas n'importe quoi et donc un
des spécialistes
c'est le français en fait ils vont la
taf voilà bon alors beaucoup de force
voire employés cette sicilienne mais
c'est vrai que le français le grand
maître français très connu pour son
répertoire tu
d'ouverture pointu igor nataf les
employés très souvent on sait que igor
travaille beaucoup avec taiwo radjabov
par exemple c'est il travaille beaucoup
ensemble
les ouvertures radjabov a plutôt opté
lui pour l'asie chez nikos oui c'est un
grand spécialiste mondial et et grenat
taf lui pour la kalachnikov
on a donc une sorte de schwytz nikov
accéléré voilà on va voir que les
petites différences quand même en ont
l'air tout de suite de quoi il s'agit
alors l'échiquier ici donc les blancs
démarrent donc c'est une sicilienne
ouverte donc que 4 c 5 cavaliers 3way
cavalli c6 donc là calisesi c'est le
coup classique qu'on va jouer pour vous
lâche technique of après les noirs
suivent par cabaye m6 on va voir que là
ça va différer puisqu'après des quatre
qui comprend des quatre caves allait
prendre les quatre ici donc normalement
le coup c 46 les noirs les blancs
répondent par câble et c3 et les noirs
ont l'occasion de jouer le coup et cinq
mais là on veut accélérer les choses et
bien stéphane en fait tout dépend pour
les noirs sicile et noir ont envie que
les blancs jouent leurs pions ces deux
en c4 ou pas voilà ça c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut comprendre dans
beaucoup de sicilienne si c'est le
fameux et tous ces détournements voilà
si on veut jouer ces quatre pour créer
les taux de marc auxi c'est à dire
empêcher le pion sert qu'a récemment à
jamais d'aller en des cinq contrôleurs
et des cinq advitam été remis parce que
les noirs ils ont déjà échangé ses 5
contre des 4 qu'est ce qu'il leur reste
à faire et le reste a échangé des cinq
contre quatre
une fois que ce pion là sera échangé
contre les pions de 4 il restera plus
sur l'échiquier qu'un seul pion central
le plus petit tapis noir voilà donc
avant d'acheter un avantage centrale
conséquent ou noir pour empêcher ça les
blancs peuvent faire un étau y passe ces
deux c4
sauf qu'en et noir leur dicte ne pas le
faire et qui joue cavalier m6 voilà six
ans seraient obligés joue dans beaucoup
de siciliano tg24 ballack a laissé 3 on
y reviendra le meilleur coup clairement
c'est de jouer cavalier fait 3 on verra
pourquoi dans d'autres le sont
ce coût est le meilleur ici les noirs de
dicte rien et joue tout de suite le coup
eux cinq ans la fille caractérise la
cécilienne kalachnikov ou 5
donc là tout de suite on attaque le cas
alors en 4 on laisse pas les blancs
souffler donc là alors eu 5
il ya un désavantage stratégique évident
c'est la grâce des six l'affaiblissement
de la case des 6 et la classe des ce1 et
l'acadien parce que tant que le pion et
aux recettes on peut envisager du bossis
et je dirais que c'est foutu futur et la
case 17 aussi là où se trouve le pion
qui fait un pion à rire et bien sûr
voilà mais bon en fait les noirs j'ai eu
5 avec l'idée qu'une fois qu'ils vont
jouer dès 5 ans qui vont parvenir à le
faire et bien le pion sera déjà en cinq
donc c'est une sorte de pari pour
l'avenir en fait on veut prendre tout le
centre et on joue d'abord eu cinq et on
déloge le cavalier des quatre qui est
très bien placé au centre menée à
l'initiative on a plusieurs coups mais
ici si on veut essayer d'exploiter
l'affaiblissement des noirs il faut
forcément recycler le cavalier sur une
bonne case et il faut jouer cavalier p5
1 les cinq dynamique alors l'idée de
calais b 5 c'est de contrôler la caisse
des silices avec la dame ici on peut
menacer même tout simplement qu'il ya
des six échecs forçant le fouet suite
assez changé en récupérant le foot 15
mois affaiblissante définitivement la
caisse des six voilà alors il ya une
petite gêne qui s'appelle la cécilienne
lau-wen-taï ou à l'oral sicilienne
labourdonnais
ou bien les noirs jouent un peu la
provoc et joue à six on peut tenter
certains bien sûr sans doute qu'on en
reparlera dans l'est dans les variantes
annexe 2 sicilienne et sur a6 alors les
blancs d'où viennent en d6 car ici c'est
l'échec fou prend des fils d'un grand
déficit lié à la pointe daniel 6006
voilà on propose l'échangé dame pour si
un échange en plus développé le cavalier
en rêve si ça bien sûr si les bleus
riches à swing faute puisqu'il est noir
gagne la suivante possible mais ce n'est
pas le plus logique ça c'est vrai
puisque là le plus dynamique puisque le
cavalier reprend attaque le plus 4 et
prépare le coût des 5
ces deux malades c'est une box et
sicilienne qui manquent pas devenant a
quand même c'est pas le sujet de notre
leçon d'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui quand même les noirs vont
s'intéresser à cette caste des six ne
veulent pas donner la paire de fou et
donc pour éviter que le cavalier en d6
il ya pas 36 solutions il faut jouer des
six nous mêmes des 6 mai alors non alors
certes c'est le carrefour
c'est là que c'est là que les blancs
sont très un carrefour alors on peut
jouer cavalier c3 carlier un ces trois
thèmes les 1 6 3 et sur à six cavaliers
apprend
retrouve des thèmes de chez nikko fin ou
dégradés pour ça que dans la leçon
d'aujourd'hui on va pas trop s'étendre
sur cavaliers un c3 puisque tous les
thèmes svechnikov vont être abordés dans
le son qui lui est propre
donc aujourd'hui on va plutôt
s'intéresser à cette variante qui est
bonne pour les blancs et qui est
intéressante qui est ses cadres ses
cadres le fameux et on sait 4,4 on va
empêcher advitam le coût des 5
par contre ce faisant on affaiblit un
peu la casse des quatre voilà le cabba
bien mieux c'est abstrait convenir
positionnelle sais que c'est pas un coût
gratuit c4 ça affaiblit la casse des
quatre mais bondées les blancs juste que
c'est plus important de complètement vie
c'est le pion en d6 donc ça c'est
vraiment la position typiques de ces
drones kalachnikov voilà c'est une
position qui est très classique
alors ici on a plusieurs plusieurs coups
le coût principal c'est fou et 7 fawcett
voilà donc on va le voir sans doute on
reviendra peut-être d'accord sont sur le
coup secondaire voilà cavaliers fawcett
ici donc on va sortir le deuxième
cavaliers voilà il faut sortir le
deuxième cavaliers pour un cavalier en
c3 pour très vite venir sur la place
vanak et seulement à ce moment là les
noirs choisissent de chasser le cavalier
bessin qui empoisonnent un peu la vie
puisqu'il est d ici à attendre que le
fou noir est un problème pour pouvoir
prendre le pion des six est maintenant
que le cavalier qui était sur la
première rangée à occuper la case c3 eh
bien on va profiter de ce passage là
pour jouer à 6 ça va forcer le cavalier
à repartir sur son camp mais sur une
casquette un peu maladroite puisque
c'est la case à 3 c sur le bord c'est ça
contrôle pas le centre c'est une case
qui est un petit peu embêtante
on verra plus tard qu'on a d'autres
idées pour le cavalier cavalière pouvoir
se recycler comme les semer en tout cas
c'est le moment c'est le bon timing pour
les noirs pour jouer à six essieux c'est
toujours le bon timing lancé quand même
deuxième et en c3 sinon il reviendra lui
mais en c3 et un risque de placer le
cavalier en d5 et se faire l'idée c'est
de se faire attaquer le site est le
premier aussi ont pas pris la relève
voilà il y aurait un relais de deux
cavaliers avec deux très bons cavaliers
qui seront les affaires et là alors là
c'est le coup kalachnikov typique 1 et
metz et metz nico viens on va dire
classique
oui mais c'est en fait c'est la raison
pour laquelle les noirs presse de jouer
la kalachnikov c'est qu'ils peuvent le
jouer ce coup là encore plus vite
il peut jouer f5 c'est la raison pour
laquelle c'est un guide n'ont pas sorti
cavalière à m6 très tôt donc ça justifie
le fait de paravent sorti le cavalier
corps est bouché le pion au cnf scène
tout de suite c'est typique on attaque
le pion aux quatre on menace aussi
éventuellement de doubler la menace avec
un 15 6 très bien placé c'est quasiment
impossible de tenir le pion 4 dans de
bonnes conditions tout à fait en général
il faut prendre quelques mois voilà mais
c'est une technique de jeu que l'on
retrouve contre chaque formation et au
dôme à roxy c'est à dire que on ne veut
pas laisser les blancs avec leurs plans
et quatre c4 pour empêcher le plan
d'alerté 5
on veut
donc s'attaquer aux bases de
l'étonnement roxy en proposant la
poussée f5 pour inciter le point 4 à
partir de sa case est aussi la pousser b
simple pour inviter le fiancé 4 à partir
fait une fois que ce depuis leur partie
alors on pourra dire des cinq et on aura
une super formation centrale tout à fait
donc on y va avec qui on prend un f5
alors pour les blancs voilà soit c'est
une possibilité soit ont fait eux prend
f5
soit on ne veut pas craqué et on protège
le pion avec food et trois ans de
civilité des possibilités food et 3
alors on va on va regarder d'abord
provincial au f5 donc là les noirs la
reprenne vise non pas se permettre de
laisser le pion si dans les blancs sont
joyeux fous détroit au coût de suivant
et ça ça fait un pion de bus du fou donc
c'est l'idée de la variante de toute
façon là maintenant les blanches au foot
est roi
voilà il faut bien sortir de ce fou à
eux deux ils seraient très passif on
voit bien qu'il serait très passif il
ferait pas grand chose oui et puis c'est
très c'est très logique de vouloir
échanger les fous de cases blanches
parce qu'on s'aperçoit que si les noirs
se laisse seul s échanger les fous et
bien on voit que les gaz et blanches
faiblesse à très faible 5 sûr aussi sûr
fcf dirais que c'est en fait un
développement avec gain de temps presse
c'est comme si le fou et est chassé
alors que c'est simplement un échange
mais c'est un échange qu élément ne
peuvent pas accepter du tout donc ils
sont obligés de trop d'autres ont moins
de temps de repartir avec le fou donc il
faut garder le contrôle est quasiment
donc ça c'est important positionnement
de train bus
c'est très intéressant c'est de vraiment
de garder ici le fou qui contrôle les
cases blanches parce qu'on voit si non
quel trou y aurait 6 avait aucun gardien
des cases blanches
donc ça c'est des erreurs que font-ils
souvent les amateurs ils sous-estiment
la
l'importante lèvres le dk de
l'importance du contrôle des cas de
couleurs surtout et le rôle des fous en
fait lancé dans cette
ce contrôle a parce que les cavaliers
évidemment peuvent changer de couleur
mais au moins de potentiel que les fous
voilà si vous perdez si vous perdez une
couleur de casser bien des pièces
blanches les pieds adverses vont
s'installer sur ces cases et là on
commence à voir de plus près les
problèmes ses avants dit que le prévoir
ses avants qui fait prévoir donc la
petit rock voilà canal et m6 lui m'a dit
qu'elle avait fait partie on va devenir
le développement cavale et c2 alors
qu'alice et de on a l'air de trouver ça
automatique c'est peut-être un coup que
vous ne connaissez pas forcément mais
c'est l'idée qu'on a à chaque fois la
cavalière en a trois pour pouvoir les
recycler on veut le mettre en étroit et
contrôler la casse des cinq une fois de
plus c'est aussi souvent la case
excellent les deux les deux sont
intéressantes pour le cavalier ou 3
voilà vous avez promis un meilleur
avenir pour le cavalier à 3 et bien ça
commence comme ça car aux yeux ces deux
cas au lieu de trois cette manière au
tipi non seulement la kalachnikov le
nomadisme est il de la suisse nous corse
au sens large public des pélicans qui
sont 2 2 2 ouvertures évidemment les
cousines des pélicans et méthodiquement
façon française de prononcer mais je
pense que ces on-dit pelican bay l'icann
du jour petit robe pour les noirs voilà
est bon je crois qu'on peut alors faire
le bilan à ce niveau là toutes ont posé
le dernier coup blanc s'est fait un
dernier dans la soirée de la vallée des
singes référence qui est une partie
qu'on a choisi entre entre post nick est
un très fort grand maître israélien pas
très connu mais mettrait très efficace
alors posté ici joue cavalier des 5 avec
l'idée banques au cas où l'iran
on va noter le petit piège voilà un
matisse etc sur cavaliers prendre des 5
évidemment les blancs reprenant des cinq
ici on attaque de pièces donc il faut
dans le jeu de reprendre fout là on dit
que tout va bien mais en fait surprise
fouquereuil chef ou prendre cette roja
prend d'un an est en fait on reprend le
fou dessert on n'a rien gagné mais on a
obtenu ce qu'on voulait faire tout à
l'heure et changer les foudres cases
blanches 3,4 à encore plus faibles et
des cases blanches encore plus faibles à
cause de la disparition du pion achètent
voilà donc les cases blanches à l'ouest
laurent blanc qui est quand même très à
la traîne a l'air on voit très vite que
des idées comme f4 son sont bonnes tout
remarche parce qu'on va ouvrir les
lignes essayé d'attaquer ce point noir
est en effet bien beaucoup de fumée sans
aucun noir on voit que l'option des six
est arriérée
les cases blanches sont faibles au roi
effet voilà et puis une dernière idée
peut-être pour le développement parce
que pour le développement du foot 15
morts parce qu'en fait on aborde quand
même ici tout est question de
développement vous avez plusieurs choses
soient f4 en l'état ou alors b3 v3 four
b2 et f4 quand même pour ouvrir une
grande diagonale foule mais deux pour un
louvre ces diagonales et on aide avec f4
voilà avec l'idée de voir cette nature
il faut le préparer mais en tout cas
c'est c'est une case d'être intéressante
pour le fou deuxième idée si vous voulez
b3 fou à trois qui n'est pas une
intéressante puisque après la venue
d'une tour en d1 il y en aurait une
sacrée pression sur le plan des six
agrès dont le sien qu'eto'o est aussi
une alternative intéressante pour ce fou
alors il faut pas prendre le cavaliere
voilà donc pour ces 8 pour les noirs
développement logique donc là on peut
faire un peut-être un petit bilan
ouverture donc on va sans doute jouer le
plan
un plan aussi avec b3 on va consolider
le pion c4 on peut envisager de sortir
le pousser dans les trois halls et les
gras centrale
on place les tours et puis on peut
commencer à ouvrir les lignes puisque
notre position est bien plus saine
stratégiquement que celle des noirs mais
les noirs qui ne manque pas de
ressources quand même avec une colonne f
alors voilà la contrepartie c'est que
les noirs en vidant une contre 9 ouverte
tant que le fou si c'est là la faiblesse
de cases blanches est relative voilà et
puis un plant l'aqsiq aussi pour
recycler le fouet cette qui n'est pas
très bien placé c'est de bouger la dame
en décèdent quand le cavaly sera parti
attention à la force cet anglicisme
attention mais voilà on essaye de
replacer le fouet cette vie via des 8
il ya des visas la classe b 6 et on veut
le ramener en tasse mais s'il a toujours
pour eve 2 voilà ça c'est des
possibilités pour toujours attaquer et
cavaliers g4 aidé à mach 4 aussi les
choses voilà les possibilités ici donc
voila voila les grandes idées pour les
noms mais qui évidemment ne peuvent ni
tram être mise en oeuvre que si les
blancs jouent de façon un peu imprécise
il faudrait regarder le cavalier ces
deux aussi qui empêche le cavalier noir
devenir en t4 alors très important voilà
effectivement ça qu'on attend avant de
le jouer en 3 c'est peut-être un peu
nettoyer la toutes les idées combien de
balayés là pour les blancs et les noirs
mais très important dans cette position
jean mathis effectivement tu ne
signalait c'est ce qu'avait laissé 2 qui
contrôlent la quasi cats il faut
absolument empêcher pleinement eux mêmes
par la surveillante en d4 qu'elle serait
une très très belle pièce qui couvrirait
la faiblesse des six voilà qui pourrait
justifier une prise dans des scènes
ultérieure et qui serait une très belle
pièce donc il faut absolument empêcher
ça le car ils ces deux suffisent à ça on
peut jouer b3 un peu je me souviens de
contrôler encore plus cette case des
quatre essayer de percer avec f4 voilà
voilà les grandes idées qu'on va obtenir
sur cette première variante alors on va
revenir
évidemment après au prend 1,5 et à la
deuxième variante rappelez vous quand
les noirs ont joué f5
voilà eh bien on appris avec l'idée
d'échanger ensuite avec food et 3 bien
sûr mais les blancs et une deuxième
option et on va regarder peut-être une
partie qui est un feu d'artifice qui est
la partie de référence sur cette ligne
là et qui est
probablement une des plus belles parties
qui candidat fait que jamais joué dans
sa vie qui est le coût des trois fous
des 3 2 3 avec l'idée évidemment jeu
augmente la pression sur m6 les noirs
prennent en tout cas très bien je peux
reprendre du fou avec un contrôle accus
accrue pardon des cases blanches et
notamment la case la case des c'est donc
ici
alors là il ya trop de pression sur le
plan f5 il faut que les noirs tous en
jouant f4 donc les noirs jouent le coup
voilà f4 il joue f4 c'est un coût normal
puisque on avait trop de trop de
pression donc il faut s'en débarrasser
et puis on prépare la taxe sur sur les
droits donc ici on voit très bien cette
chaîne de pions quand tu veux signaler
avec l'idée de d'avoir pression et
petite pression comme ça ici sur les
droits et la les blancs jouent le coup
un coup assez typique un aussi qu'on va
retrouver dans la classe caf 4 quand
même c'est un peu de la provoc et c'est
vrai qu'on se demande ce qui se passe
sur g3 qui est du coup joué par johnson
dans cette partie bien sûr j'ai trois
assez classique classique on veut
simplement dire voilà attention si je
peux prendre un f4 surprise pour je vais
bien je reprends du fou et aussi je peux
moi-même ouvrir la colonie et pourquoi
pas pour la toile à es6 et les noirs qui
craquait en prenant bien ce serait assez
dramatique puisque allons reprendre est
du pur âge on aurait une très très belle
colonnes pour la tour alors reprendre et
du pur h avec une colonne ouverte ici
pour la tour évidemment un pion aux
puces qui s'est rapproché du centre on
voit bien ses deux pions deviennent
isolé voilà parce que vraiment un très
gros problème très très gros problème
non ce serait une erreur donc g3 les
noirs peuvent pas trop prendre donc
continuer le développement comme si de
rien n'était et bien en fait on se
développe voilà donc on n'a pas peur de
perdre ce pion ce plan f qui revient va
le voir puisque après la prise chez les
pros f4 comprendre puis on prend fou
prend fou prend donc ça c'est la partie
on a sacrifié un pion voilà mais après
petit rock on s'aperçoit que le fouet f4
et bien est en mauvaise posture
c'est pour accélérer le développement
c'est tout à fait dans l'idée du granby
donc cela on a donc c
l'airé le développement on est en plein
dans l'idée effectivement de 7,2 cette
ouverture où on a
prix de l'initiative dès le début en se
créant des faiblesses et là on continue
dans la même idée à donner maintenant
guillon pour accélérer le développement
donc les noirs veulent du sang coincé
moment la volée en donnant le pur ils
ont aussi libéré la case aux 5 pour
lecavalier 6 tout arrive alors
exactement le cas ici s'il va pouvoir se
mener la bataille part au 5e rang des
communes à des belles cases en f3 ici
qu'est un 15e peu faible puisqu'il ya
plus de pions pour la défense il ya
beaucoup de trous dans la position de
parts et d'autres mais c'est les noirs
sur l'initiative puisque ils ont inventé
ce développement est parce que le roi
blanc n'a pas encore trouvé d'abris
alors on peut voir effectivement le
déroulement un peu de cette partie après
faisait trois quarts et les jets 4 kg 4
alors là on vous le montre pas la partie
pour un point de vue théorique
bien sûr c'est pour le plaisir des yeux
c'est pour vous montrer un peu avec quel
esprit on vous êtes quel esprit vous
cette variante c'est pour ça qu'on va
pas trop s'attarder non plus sur les sur
les détails sur le détail est sûre on va
regarder la suite fout d'eux pour lui
l'an qui de l'essonne et si c'est
demandé ce que voulait faire un cavalier
et ce qui ferait après fou de vélo qui
menace de prendre
il a eu la réponse très vite et il a vu
trop tard la réponse en fait car lé
premier deux décors nataf qui sacrifie
voilà du matériel et la donne ne se
rendent compte qu après fou prend il
veut et bien les noirs peuvent sacrifier
en f2 avec des fous h quatre échecs ou
h4 ou h3 et toute la famille y arriver
le deuxième vous effectivement qu'il va
pouvoir venir h3 ça va faire beaucoup
on voit d'ailleurs que donne en fait un
échec ici avec l'idée sans doute à six
reprises ici je pourrai peut-être faire
le grand roque par exemple être donc
échec aux achats suite
footpro f2 et maintenant cavale et b4
superbe dix grands nataf un jour kamal
et b4 évidemment ils attaquent la dame
des cinq et il place aux carriers sur
une très belle case ici puisque ce
qu'elle ne peut pas déloger par le pion
à temps des fêtes ça devrait bien placé
il a amassé un oeil sur les cases ces 2
et d3 ça peut toujours servir sa
immobilise c'est un coup classique aussi
un dans ce genre de partie où il ya les
deux cavaliers comme ça ici en venant
des quatre lecavalier empêche le
recyclage du cavalier à 30 ans à la dame
h5 est là et là c'est le coup tout
reprendre au magic pour prendre deux
donc c'est là où on voit c'est la
puissance et d'arnaud qu'il faut aimer
la table vaut mieux prendre des l'isthme
c'est sûrement une ouverture pour les
noirs qui est pour les grand attaquant
qui aime sacrifier des pièces pour
l'initiative mais c'est une partie qui
est absolument génial hein si vous vous
sentez pas capable de faire une chose
c'est normal c'est une partie qui est
génial vraiment ils donnent énormément
de matériel pour attirer le roi sur les
cases noires affaiblie alors bon on ne
peut pas faire autre chose que de
prendre sinon il ya bientôt une pièce de
moins alors non parce que tellement
aller à leurs ouailles travers les cases
noires sont faibles il faut prendre pour
justifier pour justifier la partie d'un
fou h quatre échecs et l'affouage 4
évidemment pour empêcher les blancs de
se regrouper
moi j'ai deux est là maintenant il a
besoin d'amener la dame sur la case g5
il veut faire un petit échec au roi pour
que parce que là l'idée pour les bleu et
blanc c'est de jouer vite tour
ah oui les fins et dernier l'euro à
cheval alors s'il se trouve une cachette
c'est fini donc g6 pas de répit faut pas
laisser le temps la dame va repartir
un petit peu dans le camp blanc la mef
troyen pas le choix permet d'amener la
dame angers 5 et pas l'autre coin
maintenant c'est une partie qui magnifie
la dame a pas d'autres coups dame g5 et
là on voit que les blancs n'ont pas de
solution il faut ramener le roi sur la
première rangée en f1 et c'est le souci
est la vente des pièces pour attaquer il
manque la tour à 8 alors que fait légaux
pour ramener la torah ville c'est simple
il manque la tour 1 8
débarrasse
ce qui gêne le plancher ils débarrassent
qui joue à 3 h 3o encore ils donnent mal
parce qu'il faut aller plus vite
possible trois échecs oran il n'y a pas
le choix pour les blancs il n'y a pas
d'autres coup obligé de prendre il faut
prendre le fou touré suite échec là on
voit que la cavalerie à rim
voilà encore une fois pas d'autre
recours que de faire flouer f3 ou f3 si
nous voulons redonner la dame mais ce
serait ça serait une catastrophe
voilà et là c'est complètement cuit en
fait puisque après la menace à la fois
tout reprend f3 menace aussi des mecs du
mat
eh bien c'est la catastrophe alors on
obligé de faire des reproches qu'à 34
seul coup se tient encore on ne peut pas
se faire mater alors là on aurait pu
prendre peut-être le fou avec tout
reprend enfouis f3 mais il doit préfère
ramener encore une pièce sur ces lacrima
de force est en fait c'est matt forcé
après qualité 3way sans rien de forcé en
quelques coups ouais c'est ma tous et
des grosses pertes matérielles très
grosse perte mais même c'est à dire que
la cavale et détroit voilà
validé c'est simple c'est que le
cavalier maintenant contrôle aussi la
kz2 encore le tout prend f3 orages et
donc pourra encore faire ton rêve deux
échecs ça fait beaucoup ça fait ça fait
même énorme donc qu'à valider cinq dames
pro f 3 voilà et cheikh mc alger 1
seulement pour le roi il ya peu roger 1
il a tout simplement qu'ils avaient eu
la tour est pris sur place c'est
vraiment avec la simple menace cavaliers
h3 mais aussi dans le prends un chien
malade ce parti magnifique migrateurs
voilà donc pouvoir était là d'ailleurs
pas la pression
donc la très très grosse attaque digoin
nataf alors donc on ça justifie ces
armes kalachnikov lors qu'on a vu le
coût est celle qu'on a vue de cofonder
trouvera ici qu'on a vu donc avec cette
idée f4 et de sacrifier du matériel donc
c'est une vie essentielles à connaître
un an cette ouverture
on va revenir oui sur une sur une petite
ligne je dirais qu'ils ne justifient pas
totalement le choix de l'ordre de coups
de la kalachnikov ces deux fois sept
cavaliers offs i sava livres 6
alors là on rentre un peu comme dans une
flèche nicole oui souvient on a laissé
les blancs jouer ces cas voilà sauf
qu'on est content en fait que les blancs
et jouissent ses cadres parce qu'ils ont
affaibli la casse des quatre parce
qu'ils ont voilà ils ont affaibli la
casse des cartes ici pour le cavaly
séisme c'est ton choix mais en général
les blancs dans la chaussée coach joue
aussi le coup c 4 souvent ça arrive ça
arrive
alors donc
voilà les six de plusieurs suites vont
regarder foot des trois peut-être et 3
dont qui sort le fou pour passer une
bonne case pour le fou de toute façon
faut 6 ici il faut aussi ce pour les
noirs voilà on continue le développement
tant parler quelle alliance étroite les
jours l'idée de la case des 5
on joue à 6 à ce moment là toujours le
bon timing et à ses trois ans je vois si
ce clavier viendra trois mal placé tout
de suite voir les d4 voilà alors suisse
alors donc c'est un peu l'idée pour les
noirs ont effectivement cotisé on a
laissé jouer ces cas donc la case des
quatre n'est pas pour te n'est pas
contrôlée par le pion c3 voilà la petite
différence rose et un plan simple c'est
de commencer par petit rock et ensuite
d'échanger ce cavalier des quatre avec
cavaliers à 3 c2 alors fou ici j'ai six
ou sept mots savants fous on sait que le
plus dur est morte ce vrai faux cette
recette
ensuite je peux jouer cavalier ces deux
pour essayer de déloger ou d'échanger ce
cavalier qui est accroché c'est ici et
fort oui au portail chelsea c'est pareil
on a cavalé ces deux donc les reprendre
sinon ça affaiblit les pions carlier
calais les grands eux d'un de france et
deux armes un fou g7 et le fameux coup
en ont parlé je pense qu'on peut clore
là dessus c'est b2 b3 b3 voilà qu'on
avait moi veut attaquer le pion des six
avec le four en a trois on veut jouer x
3 qui est aussi une des grandes idées de
ce type de mariage c'est oui ce sera
trois fois d'abord à 4 et ensuite floue
à 3 tout d'abord à quatre pour que la
tour contrôle le foin s'est sali voilà
ou parce qu'ils ne soient pas attaqués
par damas cinq également fait pas qu'ils
aient jamais
bon c'est une possibilité faudra vous
adaptez pendant les parties mais le coup
de fouet à 3 est très intéressant si les
combinés à la taille de la tour en d1
sur le plan des six à noter le foot us
est pour l'instant on n'a pas d'avenir
puisqu'il est bloqué par son propre pion
aux 5 et les noirs vont devoir essayer
de jouer f5 aussi de se libérer mais le
problème avec le plan des six voilà
c'est une ligne assez marginal quand on
joue la kalachnikov c'est rare monde
pour jouer cavalier m6 après mais bon ça
a été jouée par des paroles de grandes
est donc une autre alliance il va
connaître petite subtilité mais je
dirais un peu marginale ça rentre pas
tout à fait normal voilà donc on a vu
cette grande vente aux kalachnikovs si
cette idée donc de jouer estime très
vite et puis ces deux grandes
possibilités puis on prend un petit
coucou détroit avec une très belle très
belle exemple qu'on a vu de cette partie
de d'attac des noirs donc à conseiller
aux aux aventuriers à la tension
évidemment puisque à la moindre
imprécision c'est tout qui sait comment
ça oui on a fait des concessions
positionnelle on a des données des cases
faible au centre pour pouvoir mieux
contourner ce centre en fait c'est
toujours pareil on a voulu fermer le
centre où donner une structure de pions
fixe au centre on l'a payé le prix fort
puisqu'on a donné une une classe très
importante en d5 moment on sait que le
centre ne bougera plus et quand le
centre ne bouge plus on sait où on met
nos pièces pour attaquer voilà c'est sûr
l'idée alors là on avait eu cinq pour
fermer le centre solidifier le centre
pour attaquer ça a un prix et c'est la
casse des cinq mais on a des
renseignements très clair sur la façon
dont on doit placer les pièces après
voilà vous avez tous les renseignements
mais non pour tenter de jouer la
kalachnikov si ça vous plait ou de
savoie la contrée aussi si vous amenez
blanc pour connaître les grandes idées
voilà donc les merci jean baptiste pour
cette superbe leçon sur cette variante à
la russe à la kalachnikov
voilà je t'en prie stéphane à bientôt au
revoir